now Nicholas sturgeon has officially
resigned as Scotland's first Minister
this morning in a letter to the king she
wrote with my humble Duty I write as
anticipated in my letter to your majesty
of 15th of February to Tender to your
majesty my resignation from the office
of first Minister I propose that my
resignation take effect from the start
of the Scottish parliamentary plenary
business of Tuesday the 28th of March
2023 her resonation coming ahead of a
vote in Hollywood this afternoon which
is expected to confirm Hamza Yusuf as
Scotland's next first Minister Nicholas
sturd is saying on Twitter from me for
now thank you Scotland for the privilege
let's go to Hollywood and our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillies uh so
Connor an emotional day then for
Nicholas sturgeon that she leaves viewed
house for the last time and we wait for
the new leader
yeah a day of procedure on formality for
Nicholas sturgeon who has been in the
highest office here in Scotland for more
than 3 000 days and within the last few
minutes that Premiership is over let's
look at pictures now taking a short
while ago inside Butte house the
official residence of the first Minister
writing that resignation letter to the
king at that moment no doubt emotional
for her as she passes over the Baton to
her successor Hamza Yusuf who will be
sworn in here in Edinburgh in just a few
hours time and shortly after those
images were taken at Butte house at
Nicholas sturgeon posted a tweet let me
guide you through exactly what that says
she said just signed my formal letter of
resignation and departed Butte house for
the final time next stop Scott Pearl
here at Scottish Parliament to vote
proudly for hubs as Scotland's sick
first Minister for me for now thank you
Scotland for the privilege
the words of Nicholas sturgeon the
former first minister of Scotland who is
now making her way that short one-mile
Journey 10 minute drive down to the
Scottish Parliament here for that
Comfort confirmatory vote uh which will
confirm that Hamza Yusuf is Scotland's
next first Minister msps will vote he
has the backing of the majority of those
msps thanks to the support of the green
party the other pro-independence group
here at Hollywood but there is a big
task ahead he has to unify a divided SMP
group who have taken part in a better
contest over the course of the last
couple of weeks and let's remember tens
of thousands of SMP supporters voted for
his main rival Kate Forbes they voted
for change her slogan was continuity
won't cut it and how will he square that
Circle and bring her on board will he
pull her into the mix when it comes to
his cabinet that reshuffle that will be
coming over the course of the next few
hours and days as well will he promote
her further potentially to the post of
Deputy first Minister who knows but he
has that task of trying to unify the
party he's got clear issues when it
comes to his policies as well what will
he do with the question of Independence
furthering that cause with a movement to
our itching at the bit for that second
vote on Scottish independence how will
he make that work in a way that Nicola
sturgeon did not while at the same time
trying to win over the public support of
The Wider uh section of Scotland who are
not in support of Scottish independence
it is a huge task and we'll see more of
what happens here at Hollywood in the
coming hours